y un futbolista inglés dio un importante
paso si es un anuncio de las últimas
horas el delantero del blackpool jack
daniel's se convirtió en el primer
futbolista profesional en activos de
inglaterra en declararse abiertamente
homosexual él tiene 17 años sin milita
en este club de la segunda división del
fútbol británico dijo que está cansado
de las mentiras y que llegó el momento
de mostrarse tal y como es escuchamos
en hawai él ha pasado mucho tiempo con
mentiras he pensado y pensado cada día
sobre cómo hacerlo y cuándo hacerlo y
creo que ahora es el momento adecuado
ahora siento que estoy listo para
contarle a la gente sobre mi historia
quiero que la gente conozca al verdadero
yo mentir todo el rato no es lo que yo
quisiera hacer el antecedente más
reciente en el fútbol de un caso como el
de jay daños es el de los tele no yo
tocaba lo quien es el único futbolista
en el mundo en activo en una liga de
primera división que abiertamente ha
declarado su homosexualidad si hablamos
de un caso muy conocido está el del
alemán thomas que les perger quien en
2013 ya ha retirado ya conocer que es
homosexual fue un futbolista con un paso
importante en la selección de su país
jugó el mundial del 2006 y el conocido
como el primer futbolista profesional
que declaró serguéi es el británico
justin fashanu quien lo hizo en 1990
pero cuando no disputaba una liga de
élite falla no fue hallado muerto
colgado en un garaje cuando tenía 37
años fuera del fútbol el año pasado el
estadounidense council se convirtió en
el primer jugador en activo de la nfl en
declararse homosexual en la nba este
paso lo dio jason collins cuando jugaba
para los brooklyn nets en el rugby el ex
capitán de la selección de gales gareth
thomas fue en 2009 el primer jugador en
activo en declarar en declarar
abiertamente su homosexualidad pero
sigue habiendo mucho tabú en este tema
en el deporte masculino si neymar le
tiene más lejos hay reportes de que
dista a jay del paris saint german no
quiso jugar con el equipo este fin de
semana cuando toda la liga francesa hizo
un homenaje a la comunidad lgtb llevando
los colores de la bandera del arco iris
en las camisetas